okay here we go I was recording started
a bit late playing black against gold
moon Sun no Alexander I'd lost him off
like some the rooster mafia huh
okay now he and I had a funny win
against him with my age five line and he
probably won't repeat it repeat the
thing with short cancel that would be
really weird if he did like short
careful he does he come on you loose
like that the second time or what let's
see I mean that's not lost for white but
it's a really difficult to play yeah d4
is one of the better replies but I still
think that it's very difficult for
whites to play this position
[Music]
now I should not cancel here on mu-7 but
rather play the slowest move will be one
on d4 maybe the blacks plan is extremely
simple I just want to open up the file
the H file and play for made Queen g5 h
v it's a very crude click but also very
dangerous
yeah so do I really react to that threat
to my rook
I probably have Jim so King the age so
let's look at 7
that's a bit of a shame
[Music]
I can't play Bishop viateur
which is I don't want to do that kindiy
8 does look f7 that's not not so nice I
cannot I cannot SEC the rook that
doesn't work
what I don't like about this move is
that it's a bit difficult to to get my
pieces sorted correctly I like you know
to get them to get castling long
cancelling in okay so probably should be
should be four you might take one system
no then happy should be seven actually
okay it's an extremely wild position I
don't know probably cleaner probably my
reaction to c5 wasn't best I mean I can
also just take this pawn I probably
played it a little bit too aggressively
this this feels not not like a great
position for me I mean it's it still
it's extremely lucky but it's not
clearly better or anything which it
should be I mean the engine for example
gives black an advantage after this here
in this position already okay so he
plays for counter-attack on b7 makes
sense makes sense somehow I can take it
to but after Queen b7 everything is
hanging I mean I mean everything is
hanging
[Music]
that's not good
hmm I really have no good way to cover
this and something like b5 looks look
surrenders I am I'm in all kinds of
checks and so on what do I play yeah I
need to need to plane
they can just take your seven
I'll be seven I mean I don't think I
have enough here right so extremely
murky if it takes like Queen B seven I'm
going to just castle short and this
isn't clear I mean maybe it is but not
for me okay so everything is fairly
covered so it's not going to promote
anytime soon
you want to go back to take go back to
f3 so I need to activate this right f4 I
think I can take on default let's check
ok just goes to H 2 then or I don't know
I know if that actually helps so that
take the I mean
I still probably should have done ad am
i should have taken simply for getting
the bishop our gem now a stupid decision
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and Paul is still extremely dangerous
c-pawn check nice crab night pretty b6
ah net was still black sure if I want to
continue around time I should play
cougar
check check check check check
[Music]
black for fits on time yeah I think I
already had wriggled myself out of it I
think oh is that really working for a
make this work it does work I thought I
might have something here that I don't
now probably I probably did this wrong
early on so hear me switch that on I
probably should just take on c5 I mean
now what the stand you want to do just
now it wants to take and then take on c5
hmm
yeah I mean that doesn't work really but
okay this this is probably probably not
that gradient 95 now I have to I mean if
I have to go back that was not
successful successful
yes the engine suggests it's probably
just a bit too much but I can just take
it there's nothing really now that can
another 25 was stupid was a far too
quick quick move I mean this is
extremely murky but not not not working
yeah I should have taken on d4 yeah of
course that was a it was a mistake it
gives a bit better chances not get in
the eyes of the engine but just for
practical reasons it was better now so I
have to plate this tube a little bit too
confident there and it's surprising that
he places again because it is quite
clearly not good for white but headed
into earlier game sometimes people just
repeat the bad lines but it doesn't mean
that you have to play instant moves and
this way don't use it okay thanks for
watching